hello everyone this next game I'm about
to show you was played in 1962 in Varna
Bulgaria it was dealing beard and it was
played between mistletoe and San Joaquin
Hecht a new hotel is white and the
parking is black and if you're wondering
about the title of the video how mix
Hotel gets a kiss well we'll get to that
part very soon so tapa is d4 hex plays
Knight to f6 c4 e6 92.3 b6 the pins
Indian defense Knight to c3 Bishop to b4
Bishop to g5 Bishop to b7 III h6 Bishop
to h4 Bishop captures on c3 Bishop Derby
captures on c3 g6 nice to D to e 5
topless f3 Queen to e7 e 4 Knight B to
d7 Bishop d3 hex plays Knight to f8 he
wants to maneuver his night from f-86 to
f4 and in this position well that's
probably the best move or towel will be
the guess or maybe tell could also do a
nice maneuver with tonight to s1 - III -
maybe f5 but here tau well he found he
finds them a very nice style move and he
plays c5 and this is what all has in
mind D takes on c5 d takes on e5 and
I'll Queen captures only 5 and queen to
a4 check here has plays c6 and tau tell
castles so we have Knight to g6
attacking this Bishop on h4 and also
preparing the castle but this is why tal
sacrificed upon it was very important
for a hotel that black Queen stays on e5
he plays Knight to c4
attacking the Queen the Queen moves to
e6 and now tau
finds one more way to keep the king in
the center he plays d5 and this is
already a strange move as you can see
tell us Bishop is attacked here
so the Knights can capture the bishop
and also his allowing black to play this
bb5 thrust and although hex addition to
realize what was going on because he
thought that if he plays b5 and for the
Queen and the knight that tall would
seem to play Queen to b3 and he would
protect the night as he would be
attacking the bishop so he did he plays
pawn to b5 and in this position towel
plate he captures an f6 and now I just
want you to look at this position for a
bit so I thought Bishop is attacked here
his Knight is detect his queen is
attacked and well everything is hanging
and like I said this was a this was
quite a shock for Hecht and this is the
position that Michael that Miguel Neider
ran across the tournament hall and he
gave Michael Talbot kiss on the cheek
for this wonderful Queen sacrifice and
as soon as Paul played this everyone in
the entire hall and all the viewers were
watching this game they put it up on the
big demonstration board but hexa didn't
really take much time here so he just
played me take some a4 there's really
nothing to consider here so tell plays s
takes on g7 and threatening to capture
the rook rook the g8 and now as it
usually is with towels games after towel
sacrifices the piece and sharks you he
often shocks you very soon again with
another sacrifice so here at L plays
Bishop to f5 and Hecht says that this
Queen sacrifice wasn't really hard for
him and he was able to you know gather
his composure and keep his cool but when
he saw this bishop at five that he was
like really angry so what happens here
obviously the Queen can capture the
bishop so if Queen captures the bishop
we have this variation so we have Queen
takes on f5 Knight to d6 check after the
King moves
tall captures the Queen and after night
to h4 tall captures on h4 and this
position is well it's better for white
as you can see black has four four four
pawn islands and two of these have
doubled pawns so this would be quite a
feast for towels rooks and another move
black can play he can also capture this
night on c4 so what happens if he
captures the knight on c4 well let's see
win captures on c4 and this is what Saul
had in mind rook to fe1 check there is
no more black king can play so only only
reasonable move is to block the check
with the Queen
so Queen 36 and here talbot.blake rook
captures on e6 with check we have F
takes on e6 Bishop captures on g6 would
check so King has to move we have a rook
to d1 check King to c7 Bishop to g3
check and after King to c8 tower would
play Bishop to f7 and this rook is
captured he has nowhere to go if he
captures the pawn you get well you get
this this is quite devastating there's
nothing for black to play only move is
this and after rook captures on d7 well
this is this is completely losing for
black it's a forced mate so after Bishop
to f5 it took Hecht quite a while to you
know gather his composure and decide
what the play so in this position he
plays nice to h4 and after night to h4
tower capture the Queen and heck didn't
recapture the bishop he plays Bishop to
a six and a third game head said that he
didn't play this Bishop to a six move to
win a piece or you know to pin the night
he just wanted to capture this Knight as
he felt the night is very strong so tal
plays the Knight to d6 check Queen 37
Bishop to c4 we have ripped a true
captions on g7 the g3 protecting that g2
square
King captures the knight and now Bishop
captures an ace
and if you look at this position tall
has three pole now insect has four point
Islands but like we said that this D
soupçon islands have double spawns and
the world tall has the light squared
bishop so he can slide the board nicely
all across and this night won't be of
them are very much use so we have Knight
to f5 Bishop to be a rook to be one f6
rook to d1 check King to e7 rook to e1
check King to d6 King - f - C for G for
picking the night 97 rock the b7 rook
goes to g8 Bishop captures on c4
attacking the rook Knight to d5 Bishop
captures tonight C capture son d5 towel
place erupted before and now rook the c8
and this is the position before this
route to c8 move while engines suggest
that simply f5 or h5 would be enough for
blacks to get a drawing position but
this is the way cell place first he
forced him to spend a lot of time
although he didn't up with a queen
sacrifice and then he again with Bishop
f5 monkey force them to spend a lot of
time calculating and this is all very
tiring and now when you finally get a
chance and this is your only opportunity
probably in the game to draw the game
you simply don't have your composure and
you can find the best move
so this is one of stealth techniques he
used to beat players so rook to see a
talk at resume for text captures on c3
route de sex check King to c5 row
captors and f6 h v h3 captures captures
rook 287 and now towel pushes pawn g5
rook to h5 rub that five rub the seat to
check came to g3 King to c4 rook the e5
d 4 and now g6 update once rook the c5
check
into the three taking that broken see -
king - see - now King - at four rook the
g1 and now wrote the g5 and Hecht
resigns the game as there is no nothing
he can do this Jeep on is going to
become a queen very soon so a very nice
game I like the way that although towel
did sacrifice a queen and then offered
that Bishop at five moon and after all
the fireworks ended the towel was simply
left with a better better and another
winning endgame but a better end game
and yeah also a nice touch by miguel
neither - with the kiss and it reminds
me of a game called the american beauty
by frank marshall when frank marshall
sacrificed his Queen they say that
people were throwing gold coins on the
board so maybe I'll show you that game
tomorrow
well that's the game I hope you enjoyed
it and as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and I'll see you
soon thanks for watching